[Music]
hi everyone I'm Rosemarie Miller and we
are backstage at the Forbes 30 under3
Summit and I have the pleasure of
speaking with the CEO and co-founder
Arian Simone thank you so much for
joining me today a thank you so much for
having me absolutely so Aran first
before we get started how are you I'm
good oh thank you for asking um there's
days I'm up and down but I'm good so
Fearless fun is it's been all over the
news lately M unfortunately for all the
wrong reasons and we well for all the
right reasons we're doing amazing work
Rose y'all are doing amazing work but
the attacks against you I don't want to
be biased in my reporting but they're
unbelievable no they are unbelievable
and I don't think that's bias I just
think that's probably the general
consent or concern everybody would have
yeah yeah so could you tell us some
background in the mission of fearless
fund yes as you stated I'm CEO and
co-founder of the Fearless fund it is
the nation's first Venture Capital fund
that is built by women of color for
women of color and we got into this
space due to all the racial disparities
that exist women of color are the most
founded entrepreneur demographic they
are just the least funded and I was a
college student at Florida and
University and though it was like 20
something years ago I think I still look
20 um but yes quite a while ago and I
was Raising Capital myself and I
remember what it was like and meeting
business investors and having my
business plan this is before we were
saying pitch decks and so noticing that
none of the investors look like me and I
made a promise to myself that one day I
was going to be the business investor
that I had been looking for and that
promise looks like the Fearless fund
today backed by JP Morgan Chase
Mastercard Bank of America Alli Bank
PayPal Ventures Costco General Mills and
a host of others yes all of that mhm
just for you to have to pause it now
what what was your reaction when you
realize okay I I have to pause this
because because the grant program what
it came under attack in the 11th Circuit
Court of Appeals told yob well
everything is in pause that's one thing
I do want you to be aware of we do have
more than one business at the Fairless
fund we have our investment vehicle and
we also have our fearless Foundation at
the foundation that's where we deploy
grants that's where we have our
education program um in the program
you're referring to that the judge ruled
in our favor and then the appet court um
appeal bu it is the MasterCard Grant M
and we have a program with them that
we've been running for quite some time
they made a commitment post George Floyd
to the black community of a certain
dollar amount that they wanted to get
out into the black community and we're
here to be a fund ad minister to that
program so what was your reaction when
you knew you had dep pause it um we
always knew that that was an option we
knew that the judge can choose to rule
either way uh of course it's always
disturbing we got into the space because
there's actually a need but I actually
want the same things in in this world
that Ed Bloom does yeah I know you're
like what is that or world where race
doesn't matter okay I want the same
thing he does our just way about going
about it has to be different because we
have to get to an equitable space before
that day can happen so how long do you
believe you're going to be dealing with
this lawsuit oh honestly I have no clue
that's in the judge's hands that's in
the judge's hands I'd love to be out of
it
yesterday I imagine I imagine I I I
entrepreneurs these especially black
women they're they're facing so many
challenges with getting funding as you
already mentioned could you tell us some
details or some stories rather of exact
challenges that you've seen well we know
the statistics are what they
are black and brown women right now are
receiving 0.39% of venture capital
funding while making up 20% of the US
population again most founded least
funded so the stats are what they are
but I would like to share a personal
story about somebody who happened to
just slide in my DM and she was like oh
Aran I'm getting ready to pitch the fund
and I let her know I said oh your
business necessarily doesn't necessarily
match our thesis and she wanted to stop
and just go change her business model
her her Focus everything and I said
ma'am no no no no I said your business
is actually like really really good like
I don't want to call her out cuz her
business is really good and I'm pretty
sure she's probably like a seven fig
earner going plus and
growing but I said don't change anything
she said I don't think you understand
you are my only hope and I was like wo
like my whole Spirit stomach everything
just dropped I'm like people view us as
their only hope this is a problem so my
plan after finishing we're in the middle
of a fundraise now for um fun two my
plan after this that I told my staff
back in June um January before all this
happened that I wanted to get into some
policy work to make changes regarding
access to funding because I don't want
the next next person who's black or
brown to come behind and try to start a
fund and they have to go through all we
went through just to get to the 25.8
million in a in a concept fund it was
like 300 meetings yeah I don't want that
for anybody um so I was always going to
take a moment after that fund raise and
just work on changing the landscape some
and then I'm like okay as long as I can
make it better for somebody else I've
done my part because the Fearless fund
is great but we need Fearless funds with
an S we need many people doing this in
order to move the needle know St
statistics I'm curious she said you are
my only hope oh that was horrible what
led her to believe that because I know
in the world of business you get
accustomed to hearing a whole lot of NOS
but all you need is that one yes do you
think you were really her only hope or
did she just endure too many
NOS um I think that she probably has
like many endured too many NOS yeah yeah
there are options out there but I mean
if you like I said you heard the stats
so you can just imagine heck look at us
when we had to fund raise 300 meetings I
mean 300 yeah it took a minute it took a
minute over how long oh gosh over about
a threee period like it's no joke it is
no joke so what what kept you motivated
um I knew what I said to myself back in
2001 sitting on that floor of my store
in Tallahassee Florida in the
Tallahassee Mall while I was a student
at Florida and University um but I'm
pretty resilient I mean the word
Fearless is not just our company name
for no reason I'm I'm going to keep
pushing what made you a resilient woman
I grew up in the city of Detroit
Michigan okay and raised by amazing
parents so that's the short version of
that MH I want to hear more you want to
hear more I want to hear more I want to
hear more um the city I grew up in was
about 88% African-American and I got to
see black success at its finest I got to
see people who were billionaires and
multi-millionaires and these were people
who were reachable we used to pay the
cable bill to Barton cable vision we
didn't pay it to AT&T we didn't pay it
to Xfinity we didn't pay it to any of
these companies we paid it to Barton
cable vision this was a black man who
owned that company so every month I got
to see my parents pay the cable bill to
this black man who owned this company
and I it didn't Empower me then I just
see how it had an effect on me later I
saw what was possible man was about a
nine figure earner you can walk down the
street and go speak to him wow mhm and
seeing that that made all the difference
growing up and seeing that oh yes the
exposure seeing that what was possible
and what your options were most
definitely so what three pieces of
advice do you have for someone on how to
be resilient oh my
gosh um to pull from the child within
cuz children oh my gosh if they want
something they going to keep on asking
until they get it you best believe they
will throw a whole tangum to get what
they want so pull from the child within
pull from the God within um and keep
yourself surrounded with good energy and
good people I love that especially pull
from the god with it well thank you so
much for joining me here today oh thank
you thank you for having me
absolutely